こんにちはー to sleep ラーメンです今日また歯
言葉の勉強について
はが左の考え方について話ししたいと思います
言葉を勉強するときにまあ英語なら英語中国語なる中部スペイン語なぁスペイン語
まあ日本語なる日本語ですね
やはり目標があればですねそれ
その6目標たするためにやはり戦略が必要なんですよ
戦略なぜかというと a
言葉の勉強というのはねひとつの新しい言語言葉を勉強するのはですね
長期戦ですよそれがあのこれ早くすぐできるようなもんじゃないですよね
当然将棋線その長期的にその目標を達成するためにですね
目標はいえば流暢に話せるという大胆人が小いう目標を持ってますけれどもその目標を
達成するためにどういう戦略がひっ
仕様は何ですか
必要なんでしょうか
私神の音げー原敬嬪ではですねー
戦略的にその
りスイングをリスニングの能力を開発するの会
一番黄ばんだと思います一番大切なんですよ
十分にですね理解できるならば
聞いた時に理解できるならばですね
すべてその他のあのー
治るわけですね
各能力
話す能力
に読む能力すべて同時にあの発展するんですよ
外国号で何かを読むときに
僕自身の場合はね
やはり自分の頭の中にですねこの言葉を聞いてます
英語で言う3部を伺えず読みながら発音は大きな声で発音しませんけれども
お腹あの頭の中で発音しますだからその4内容
よくまあ村木場合はね大部分の場合はこの前には所に聞いてあるんですよ
だから読むときに大体どんなどういう風に発音するのかですね
頭の中にあるんですよ読みながら英語事務所住んだことはないんですよね
英語は自分の母国語ですからまあ皆
3日本語の日本語は日報ここであれば日本語よ無敵読むときにも食意味
速く読めるしかし他の言葉を読むときにですねどうしてもやはりおとう聞いてあの
聞きながら呼びますだからあのー
てぃく能力が非常にいう意味では大切
それから話するときにもですね
たぁさん聞いたいろんなフレーズとか単語を聞いた
そのフレーズと単語の応答発音がね
自分の頭の中にあちこち走ってるような中でですねそういうフレーズとか
単語引き出すとそれ8
会話の中に使うとだから
その気9ターンさん聞いてそれを頭に入れる
そう言うと同時にですね読むときでもですねそれで僕の場合はあの
聞くだけではなかなか記憶できない
もちろん寄付聞くのもですね
dark さん十戒も二次会もはいいろんな
違った内容で処理を a
聞いたらあるいはそういうその繰り返しですよ同じものを聞くという衣装があるんです
よ
記憶するためにねただ沿っ聞くだけではなかなか把握できないです
だから
よむよむ目標の一つはそれを聞いた場合はわかる
だから読むのも読むこともやはりその聞く能力をアップするあの
やはり役割もあります基本の戦略は
聞く能力菊の菊
理解動画アップする見えためにもですね
やはり合意を増やさないといけないこの単語が知らないと聞いても
だからそういう意味でもあるいは書くときでも
あの
建物
僕は日本語で書きます場合はね
今は体で書けないんですよ忘れました
ひらがなでも感じでもかけないですよ前は忍者一緒に先祖頃はまあある程度書くことで
きましたけれども今じゃできない
しかしコンピュータでできますコンピュータだワープロでできます
何をラックかというと前に聞いた
いわゆる聞いたプレージア単語
2今私がし話しているようにですね
話蔓ももう手で書くわけですよ
だからすべての基盤は
聞く能力菊の量だから聞くのよく
アップするのするのもですね一番のまあ目標なんですよだから
今その停車後のアラブ語を勉強している時でもですねぇー
まず
通ってカー氏と聞いて分からない選んで
単語やフレーズセーブしてまた聞いて
で場合によってはですねイランの方に頼んでその聞くそのまま彼女はいろんな自分の
生活についての簡単な5分ぐらいのストーリーを作ってくれるんですよ
それいい
いいましてからその短縮キャプションで際いわゆる文字を作るわけですよね
非常に生きて面白い
そのないよくないよくないですよないそれに対するまだ質問を彼女多くが作るんですよ
ですその何かこの彼女のストーリーの中にその
一つのセンテンスですねプレイずを
そりゃ彼女は例えば
音楽が意識だと
それで必ずあの彼女は音がベッキーですかといっ
彼女はあのー
が詳しいですあるいはいいえ
額は好きじゃないとそういうような簡単な質問
それもあの別にその質問国聞いてですね
考えて彼女は遠いましたかこのストーリーの中にそれを別に寄与する必要はないです
ただ
もう一度繰り返してその
一つの園
ないますかしていくとかですっ
していくついてあっあってそれに対する正しいですか正しくないですかあるいはどこで
それに対して質問が出る
それからまた返事それ全部聞くわけですよ
別に考えなくて女ただ繰り返してくれ快適9勝することによって少しずつ聞く能力を
アップすだから
なの言葉の勉強の時にですねその投影国
立ててやぽいな閉館相手もですね菊の量が良ければ
早く読める
聞いてもすぐ意味わかる
ダーツが利いた場合ですね何が正しいが何が正しくないかっていうのはすぐ分かるわけ
ですよ
別になの分布の得る考えなくても
だから当駅でも ios でもなんでもそういう試験のためにでも
聞く能力それをだからリスニングはですね
に重点を置けば戦略として全て
統一も含めてよくなりますだから何がメインのもう
勉強活動というか何がメインの戦略というかあくまでそれは
リス人でどうやってそのリスティングをアップするかというのを戦略的に非常に意味が
ある
税
listen はですねいつでもできますサラライナー時に車の中電車の中でいつも
できましただけれども時々
その聞いてもわからないだから聞いてわからないときに戦い読めないといけない
あるいは先がこの僕は言いましたような質問
荒野
こうですよと
こうですかはいそうですあるいはまあ
彼女はへ
東京の大学東京大学で数学を勉強してます
彼女は東京大学で体数学勉強してますか
いいえ彼女は東京大学で数学勉強します
大彼女は遠く彼女は東京では良いで勉強しています
彼女はどこで勉強してますかあの所は統計代役でメイクしてます
別に考えなくても繰り返す区
り返しことによってメインのストーリーの方がわかりやすくなる
そしてもう一度聞くだからいろんな工夫すればやはり
理恵
戦略1もとにかくれ新
レシービングリスティングですね理解度それをアップするのが一番思うよそれをあの
できるなら他のすべてのその
昨日というかその
能力があって
それに伴ってよくなりましじゃお前だと
やならん